how many of you are following the
Olympiad if you have been following or
you haven't been following you should
know that the US team is in first place
right now they they beat well they're
playing Poland tomorrow
they beat Asura by John today yeah and
the women's team beat Italy today and I
wasn't planning to show like too many
olympia games but i found one
looking through the games this morning
and i found one which would fit in
nicely to this the theme of this lecture
and the theme of the lecture is going to
be maximizing your advantage essentially
what to do when you get a good position
and how to essentially grow your
advantage and and then hopefully convert
a winning position so i want to start
with a game played by tata abraham ian
who i'm sure most of you know she has
purple hair anyone know her favorite
animal yes yes
she likes penguins so yesterday i was at
the zoo and i have a picture here I saw
the Penguins so I took it I flicked some
photos of the Penguins I sent them to
her as like good luck and then she
played just an amazing game today and
beat her opponent like very quickly so I
have to take some credit for her fight
today
yeah the puffins are in the same areas
the Penguins in it it's it's a little
bit confusing but you should tell the
difference but on all seriousness I mean
she played a really nice game and she
didn't really get an advantage in the
opening but once she got the advantage
she just rolled over her opponent so I
want to go through the game won't spend
too much time on the opening does anyone
know the name of this opening after
Queen c7
yeah yeah teamwork there Sicilian
Tamannah
yeah this is one of my favorite openings
as black and there's many ways to play
against it as white I mean any logical
looking move here is a line Bishop III
is a main line Bishop e2 is more
classical line g3 is becoming more
popular these days taught to have played
a much more aggressive variation
starting with f4 and they followed what
is pretty main line theory they got a
structure where white is usually just
developing normally and getting ready
for some later King side attack and I
want to get to yeah let's get to this
moment we're so far Tata F is just play
normal moves the last move King h1 very
typical Sicilian move when you advance
the pawn to f4 you want your King not to
be exposed along this diagonal and now
it's blacks move and I was actually
pretty impressed with blacks preparation
because black essentially managed to get
to a point where it was just about equal
and black played pretty forcing Lee here
starting with taking the pawn on e4 and
I take e4 more trades on e4 and then
black plays a nice move 85 and a5 has a
very specific tactical purpose what is
black threatening to do anyone yes
Bishop b4 is one idea what's other idea
with a 5 yes yeah so essentially trying
to make both bishops more active in the
position and Bishop a6 is a useful
useful positional idea I mean it looks
like a skewer at first but if black is
able to get this move in it would force
a trade of whites good Bishop for blacks
bad bishop
so from here rook f3 is played Tata vis
trying to go for some attack and then
after a Bishop a6 the Queen moves rook
to Yeats and now Bishop c3 so from this
position it looks like white is is
really nicely set up to to further
attack on the Kings side given the
bishops are in great
the rook is ready to come over to h3 in
some cases the Queen can come to h4 and
this is actually a very critical moment
for black and I want to pose a question
here black to move what would you play
you see this kind of scary attack coming
what should lack do to - perhaps
neutralize the play suggesting f6 will
make Ben Feingold very upset it's a move
probably weakening you said rook rook e8
okay Ashish Bishop b4 yeah so black
should in this position play Bishop b4
this is I think this is just the most
natural move basically attempting to
force six change of the bishops
suspicious is so strong especially
because box committed to g6 the dark
squares are pretty weak around the Kings
side and if black can just trade off the
bishops it should be approximately equal
and it's very common like in this case
where black is a one probably it's the
one eating to defend in the middle game
the more pieces are traded the easier it
is to defend now let yeah question
hmm yeah actually Bishop f6 is
interesting but you are giving away the
rook and I would be concerned as white
in this position that the back rank
could be vulnerable oh you want to take
on d8 first but that trades more down
and black would be happy going into a
position like this
I mean Queens could get traded lot could
even take back and then maybe use a D
file in Queen d6
and like can't challenge with rook t3
because this bishop on e6 so if black
played Bishop before I think it would
have been equalizing it would have been
hard for a white to push for a win but
all it took was one careless move from
black for white have it just a massive
attack this position or actually no I
take that back it took two mistakes from
black one was a kind of slow move this
move rook F e8 and then later we'll see
the the blender yeah you said rook fe8
so you're playing like the Italian board
was abort three or four who's rated
about I think twenty to twenty three
hundred the problem with rook F e8 it's
a bit slow and it gave tot of time here
to play a very useful move so having
understood what we just looked at what
should white play in this position and
tot of did find the right move here yeah
yeah a3 and I think knowing like knowing
box idea really helps in finding a three
even though a three looks like a slow
move it turned out to be a very useful
move in limiting any sort of counter
play and also preventing any traits I
think a lot of you guys would be may be
inclined to attack right away with a
move like rook h3 or maybe Bishop e5 but
a3 is a very nice patient move and
sometimes when you're you're kind of
looking over high-level games you might
skip over and
like a three not realizing the
importance but here it's just so
important especially to restrict this
bishop and keep this good Bishop on the
board and this is where black black
essentially was careless and blundered
I'll go ahead and say that the best move
for black is to still try and initiate
some trade and the best move actually
looks really weakening here but it is is
helping black is to play f5 to chase
away this bishop force the trade of
light squared bishop s-- and then get
some position like this where things
could tray down even further and whites
still slightly better but white won't
have like a massively crushing attack
they do move like Bishop f8 here to go
to g7 and mmm I mean it's pleasant for
whites but nothing nothing decisive well
black did instead was played Bishop d6
which turned out to have no use in the
position actually turned out to be going
for the completely completely wrong idea
and this gives white a lot of a lot of
time to create initiative yeah
Bishop F fade in this position hmm yeah
that's probably a better move than then
what happened as you'll see the bishop
on g6 did not play a defensive role and
this is where black begins getting into
trouble now light to move what would
talk to play yeah
Queen H work very simple very logical
this has multiple mating threats who can
tell me what's one mating threat yes
Queen h6 yeah I would threaten me on g7
but that allows Bishop f8 so Queen f6 is
one threat yeah threaten me on h8 also
yeah
Bishop f6 followed by Queen OH followed
by Queen h7
yeah like the media thread is queen h7
right queen h7 king take h7 rook h3 you
don't need your bishop on f6 to do that
so maybe this is one black mist was the
fact that Queen h4 is just threatening
so many things in black is now in a
situation where I mean it's necessary to
defend against mate
and black went for a 5 this is probably
the idea with with starting with Bishop
d6 but we're going to see this only
helps white open the position further
taught to play very simple move rook h3
and then Bach played at five so Bach is
trying to extend expand and chase away
in this case the white bishop but in
extending the pawns like this it's
weakening to the Kings side and now
white to move I think there's a few good
moves here for whites anyone want to
take any suggestions is that a hand
attack you said take on e5 bishops a key
five and then let's say Bishop taking
five take on e5 pawn to g4 black is up a
piece here
and h7s defended so now if you're in the
sacrifice you want to get be getting
compensation so after a bishop taking
five upon taking five in this position
ah pawn to g5 that's very possible
if bishop tink if you're in the play of
forcing moves like this you need to
calculate this should take out five here
aha could get a bit murky Bishop takes
c3 after a five in this position
Oh Bishop takes c6 here yeah this is a
messy line and not sure if Bishop takes
c3 probe taking eighths oh this should
be working uh
take take and then I mean this should
take b2 it's still a bit of a mess I
mean what why does up the exchange in
this position I want to go back because
taught to have played I think just too
clearly maybe a simpler move the thing
to understand here is okay look after f5
the Queen defends h7 so so we want to
look for perhaps other ways to advance
and and get to the the black King one of
the best moves here is to take advantage
that of the fact that the queen is tied
down is and just to take on c6 attacking
they were keeping initiative and in the
Queen can't recapture because of Queen
take age 7 but Tata I think played an
even simpler move I'm focusing more on
the King side simply Bishop take i-5
yeah I think I heard Bishop take f5 if
you if you saw this very nice because
now what happened the game black took
back black doesn't take back I mean
Bishop take g6 is probably a threat its
Queen g7 well White has won a very key
pawn and now there's a pin so I wouldn't
be surprised if I could just play a move
like Bishop b4 here just have a very
strong advantage but okay black accepted
the sacrifice in the game and this is
where just the compensation is enormous
and white is completely winning after
rook g3 king f7 and now just pawn take
e5 Queen take aged 7 is probably also
winning pawn take e5 I mean it's also
effective because this h7 pawn
really be defended and relaxed
physicians falling apart there's a main
one threats with the Queen f6 and
sometimes when you have like a strong
attack and you're looking for ways to
keep the initiative you want to not just
consider the checks
I'm sure Tata was considering moves like
Queen take h7 and queen h5 which are
probably working but she probably just
saw that taking on e5 was stronger and
after rook take e5 Bishop take e5 Bishop
take e5 Queen take aged seven I mean
black I think black resigns here the the
Queen is either lost or black standing
made it or both if King goes to f8
there's rook g8 mates if King goes to f6
there's rook g6 mates if the King goes
to the e-file this Bishop would be
pinned and then Queen take h7 so for
example here Queen take c7 so all
variations white is just coming out
ahead so this was a relatively quick
game I mean OMA almost a miniature I
think a miniature is classified as a
game 25 moves or lastest is 26 moves but
it came from an opening where okay White
was in good shape to attack black
slipped up a couple of times first by
not playing Bishop before immediately
and then not finding this move f5 to try
and simplify things and then white white
was just overpowering so if you guys are
not following the loop yet I would
highly encourage you to do so for the
people watching on YouTube if you're
watching this only be it's probably done
so you can always go back and see the
games anyway let's move on I want to
show not necessarily more full games but
rather like key moments key positions so
we're going to move on to this position
and I will guarantee that no one except
me in this room has seen this before
this came from one of my students games
my student was playing black and upon
like looking over this game I was
cringing when I saw a box physician
around here it's like like the kings on
that faith box severely underdeveloped
White's pieces are active light has an
amazing Center now my student actually
went on to win this game as black which
was incredible like given given this
physician my students rating is about
1900 was playing a player
I think Raiden also about 1900 and this
is a situation which I think will happen
in a lot of like amateur level games
where one player will get an advantage
and then not know what to do with it
and in this case White's advantage is
only temporary if you give black a few
moves to maybe play an efficient B six
Bishop e7 kingi a trick f8 we should
count material if I can count correctly
black is up upon even though it doesn't
feel like it yeah that to the outside
pass pawn can later run down the board
and this is sort of how how black did
end up winning was white wasn't able to
capitalize and then a pawn proved to be
decisive so I want you guys to think in
this position give you some time this is
not something I would expect anyone to
see right away but think about what to
play for whites look for maybe some
forcing variations and try and be as
accurate as possible to grow the
advantage ken west with the Henry's
right away yeah Queen f4 check
Queen f4 would play Kings Yates and you
want to play rook F 3 and then okay you
want to meet on f8 so I only see one
move for a black Queen e8
not so easy I mean you know you know
you're better but no like the Queen and
the bishop kind of gets stuck we'll get
to that I just want to make a point this
is what happened the game the the player
playing white played Queen I for work f3
and then it didn't work out
so you're saying d5 at what point and
after Oh in this position d5 right away
Rudy five can make some of the board
I have to think here I'm tempted just to
just take the pawn if you're gonna play
d5 you have to have some follow up ahead
of time
Queen c5 King G it's got three Queen yet
Wow looking pretty good ooh but fish
about five could move Hoos are coming
very rapidly what if rook c8
Queen a3 oh that's also possible Queen
take d5 with check but then the bishop
is hanging you want to play Queen a3
wait one it's time
so you're saying Queen a3 this is
looking decent
maybe rook c7 it's getting very messy
it's very possible like you could be
better from this line it's possible you
can lose control because the White King
is also quite exposed so I want to go
back I will say they're like d5 is
really interesting it can lead to a lot
of possibilities but there is a more
controlled way of playing and there's a
very clear way like can get it like a
clear advantage here yeah interesting
okay so from an intuitive standpoint
you're you're absolutely right Queen
if you're considering between Queen f4
and Queen f2 you should be inclined to
play Queen f2 for two reasons one reason
you want to what you want the rook to
lead the battery additionally you don't
want your Bishop to be blocked on g5
where it can't move so I want to focus
on on this line because after Queen f2
King G aids rook F 3 is a nice forcing
move we're forcing Queenie 8 also a
quick question what to play after h6
it's on an alternative defense but it it
runs into massive problems yeah
that looks really strong cleanup six is
coming what if what if Queen a for
though King dick g7 King g8 wait is
there force meet here
so you're saying here if King h7 there's
Queen f7 and Bishop f6 meet so Queen
take g6 King East or King to f8 kini 7
Queen g7 kt8 Queen f8 here
has anyone calculated force mate are you
just you guys are just trying to play
checks Queen d6 King yet I want to go
back all the way like this this might be
okay
but if you're gonna sack your rook you
need to see the final you need to see
the final position if this is a
practical game sometimes you you you
just want to be as controlled as
possible and like if you have the time
you want to calculate if you can find a
win in those variations you can perhaps
calculated it out but in this case
before playing rook f7 immediately
there's another move to consider here
yeah I think they should take h6 is just
the simplest approach if Ponte gauge
Sixers rook f7 if King take h6 is Queen
h4 means make sense so sometimes there's
a there's a common problem on among
players where you'll see a forcing
variation and you'll dig so deep and
then that might cause you to overlook
just a simpler move that doesn't require
as much calculation so sometimes you
have to focus on like the breadth of
moves that you're considering rather
than depth so that was that was one key
variation so we can safely conclude that
h6 is is losing because of this line so
Queen e8 is the only move now this is a
very key position because like from the
story it's very possible to calculate to
this this exact position but then the
question is what to do next and this is
kind of another exercise in itself so
light to move here what to do now I
think I'll take a different approach
this time instead of like analyzing one
variation and moving on its next
variation I just want everyone to think
and determine what movie would
play initially from this position okay
we have one Henry's what you think is
sheesh which for okay
any other ideas
d5 okay yeah Brooke h3 okay so so far we
have Brooke h3 Queen h4 and d5 I'll go
ahead and say no one has found the
strongest move yet
and a position like this
I want to perhaps introduce a new
concept of thinking where essentially
you want to cycle through different
candidate moves this is called
progressive thinking so it might be easy
to get caught up in lines with like d5
or Queen h4 and looking for something
immediate but there's a very very
important skill in being able to like
continually look for new ideas so
there's a different completely different
idea here for whites that's you guys
need to kind of expand your your your
outlook on the position yeah
Queen e1 to b4 I like the creativity
that's the possibility keep searching
yeah
Bishop f6 with sacrifice but after after
you take back on f6 is Queen f7 but I
like the fact you're you're you're
considering more and more resources
what's another another resource for
whites
okay Queen a2 to a3 it's slow but okay
as long as you're considering more ideas
this is a focus
yeah and and sometimes you can combine
these moves so like we need to combine
with d5 could be an idea still we have
not arrived at the strongest idea here I
want to ask a simple question which
piece is misplaced in this position
which piece for white is not doing
anything this Bishop on g5 if we can
place the bishop anywhere on the board
where would we like to place it
everyone's saying a3 yes so or d6 mainly
we want to place it along this diagonal
so the the key move here like once you
ask yourself the right question the move
comes she very easily Bishop c1 it's
incredible move it's like a backwards
attacking move you move backwards but
you reposition on the best square and
the whole idea is that f8 will very soon
be in White's control Bishop a3 is
unstoppable the Queen's tied down to
defending f8 and black is just too slow
here if Bishop d7 Bishop a3 and now
we're cafe this is unstoppable so it's
not yeah it's a Karpov yeah it's very
patience but very strong so I think this
goes to show like even when you have a
clear advantage it can still take a lot
of effort and energy to play in the most
precise fashion and here it was I mean I
would have been very impressive if if
the white player found found this
bishops you want to a3 maneuver
I think the Queen f2 move wasn't
necessarily so hard but but yeah this
would have been pretty spectacular so
one big takeaway and this is more of a
psychological lesson but when you get
into a winning position or when you when
you know you how the clear advantage
don't get relaxed you get to relax
that's when you can start miss playing
things and play a bit more inaccurately
you really have to like devote all your
energy and focus to finding moves
fighting moves like this when when the
position calls for it
any questions let's move on I do have a
lot of exercises we're not going to get
through all of them debating which
actually let's let me show you guys the
scheme hopefully all of you have heard
of capablanca maybe it's possible that
some of you have seen this game you've
seen this so this this position is
published in the book reassess your
chess by jeremy Suleman which is a great
book highly recommended for for like
intermediate players looking to expand
their positional knowledge and this is
one of my favorite examples of how to
convert a space advantage actually have
the question here what is White's main
advantage clearly white has more space
right but the position is completely
locked down and the question is okay
white house space but material is equal
there's not any immediate like clear
targets or weaknesses to attack so the
question is how does whites go from
having more space to winning the game
and I think this is a really instructive
sequence like from this position how to
treat a space advantage and how to
operate in these circumstances where you
like if you're playing white you
basically have a limited time to
reposition your your pieces if you have
a question or suggestions so I want to
pose a question here and the question I
want to pose is what is blacks main
weakness what is the thing in box
position which could lead to the whole
downfall and basically what what thing
can very easily be attacked or maybe not
easily but eventually be attacked yeah
that's a b7 plan who else wanted to save
you something
something different maybe the a file
gotcha
yeah so it's kind of you want to use the
a file to potentially attack b7 and I
think the best way to kind of show the
strategy here is just to play out the
moves and and just admire the way
capablanca executed his opponent in this
position rook a one rook c8 and I think
you mentioned Queen c7 but it's I think
more effective to have her work on on a
7 or a sari Queen a 7 but we want the
rook to lead the battery so he plays
Queen d4 and abling or k7 now it's still
hard to attack this pawn more times but
okay White has time King f8 now the
other row comes in King g8 and we see
black is just so cramped and it's so
difficult when you have less space but
you still have a lot of like pieces on
the board like three major pieces two
minor pieces this Bishop is so sad the
night is so sad like the night's
completely restricted the knight would
love to like someday come to you for but
there's no path of getting there so what
we'll see as Bach was pretty much just a
badge to wait until his inevitable doom
so we're gonna keep going here at rook
a4 which is important move because we
want the we want to triple up but we
want the Queen to be the last piece in
the battery King out faith Bach is
waiting Queen a3 now it still takes work
rook e8 doesn't work here because black
still has three defenders on eight so
this is where it takes another another
resource to apply pressure now I like
this move King g3
some of you might be inclined if you had
this position to try and maneuver the
Knight to a5 immediately which is a key
plan
if we play 92 here this is a bit
careless because we're missing blacks
potential counterplay yeah yeah and I
take g5 is a move we just don't want to
deal with it's very possible this move
could end up fine for whites but we
don't want to deal with ok the sacrifice
the Queen comes to h2 and then the whole
dynamic of the position changes so you
don't want to give back any chances
that's why capablanca put the King on g3
and then he put the King on h4 like the
king is safe on h4 yeah yeah the knight
moves to d2 then g5 was just hanging
it's true I'll see if what's the King to
h4 King any chains and then if I
remember correctly something really
funny happened Capablanca just started
waiting around and then he changed his
mind he didn't want his King on h4 he
wanted his King on g2 he realized that
this is the best square so he's being
very very patient like he's basically
wasting so many moves but it doesn't
matter because he has so much time like
black can't do anything and the King on
g2 is probably right that it's it's
safest it's controlling g3 and h2 so
there's no sacrifice is where the knight
can come to take on g5 and the Queen can
penetrate and then from this position
this is where it can begin the night
maneuver and Keyvan light comes to a5
there's two attackers on d7 Black has
one way to defend e7 which is 98 and now
white to move so white has essentially
applied almost maximum pressure but
there's actually there's one more way to
increase the pressure this is kind of
like the last straw that breaks the
camel's back like to move in this
position how to increase the pressure
even further you want to take twice on
b7 and then play Bishop a6
so mm-hmm that's possible - and both of
your ideas are probably just fine but
they're both sacrificing there's a move
Capablanca played which doesn't really
sacrifice anything yeah oh you know the
games you want to say the move yeah
vision basics rather than like
sacrificing on b7 okay this looks like a
sacrifice but this Bishop on g7 is
undefended it's so beautiful why just
lined up all the pieces on a file and
this whole plan was pretty much
unstoppable
from the moment white just closed down
the position because Bach had no no
active counter play that was great like
capablanca x' technique in the way he
was just so patient making sure there is
no no counter chances and now there is
uh there's three attackers on b7 just
kind of hard to imagine ahead of time
but yeah now from here black falls apart
very quickly he took Brooke take to you
7 g7 and now I think there is one more
move and then black resigns yeah nice
job Rick take to you because after rook
take d8 here's Mike take c6 and just
completely win the family for usually
the family for concludes the king but
most of the family yeah and a six will
fall why it will have two connected
passers
so I really like the scheme because it
took one advantage which his face and it
took a while but eventually white was
able to convert it to just a massive
material advantage which sometimes in a
lot of games you don't see it work out
like this this smoothly in the words of
Maurice Ashley but it works in this case
it worked out well so let's move on so I
first came to the st. Louis chest
back in 2010 they opened I believe in
2008 yeah you know best were you here in
2008 Wow oh okay well okay I was here I
was invited for the US Junior
Championship which the Chess Club has
hosted for the last I think in 2010 it
was her first time hosting it and then
since then they've had they've had nine
nine Junior events here so far right
yeah so anyway I was playing Sam Jenkins
at the time he was an international
master and actually before before the
tournament started he made like a public
that was announcement or interview that
he was gonna quit chess after after this
junior tournament he was so fed up with
like these uh these open events where he
was trying to get his final Grand Master
norm he wasn't getting it so he said
he's just gonna quit chess and okay you
guys know where he is now so clearly he
didn't quit but one of the reasons why
he didn't end up quitting was because he
won this this junior championship
tournament and that qualified him for
for the US Championship the following
you I qualified him for the world junior
championship and one of the reasons why
he won this tournament was he beat me
so I might be able to take credit for
him for him continuing chess and
eventually becoming US Champion what was
interesting also was he lost the first
two games of this junior event and then
he came back he was on a huge winning
streak I was a victim of the winning
streak and he played a played a really
nice combination against me I forget who
exactly beat him it came down to an
Armageddon playoff in the end between
him and Ray Roxon and he just completely
crushed ray with a Carroll Khan is black
it might be online somewhere you can
probably find it but I want to focus in
this moment from our game Shanklin is
playing white I'm playing black we have
we have a position that came from a
Queens gambit declined which is a type
of structure that he very you see very
often in the Queens gambit declined
White has a lot of pressure on the C
file has already played a 3 B 4 mi C
pawn is on a sad Packard pawn however I
have some counter play for it I have the
open H file and I have I have some nice
initiative on the Kings side too as
we'll see I play Queen h3 here
threatening them this this made in one
and then he plays Knight H for defending
and now in this position I made a
mistake I actually made the probably the
losing mistake of the game well I should
have done was play Queen e6 I should
have just repeated the position and then
he he mentioned after the game that if I
played Queen e6 he was probably going to
play another three and be completely
okay with the draw however I played
Queen d7 here
Knight g4 would be okay I would probably
consider that if if we went down that
line I want to focus on this position
because this is a very critical moment
and this is essentially the the turning
point in the game where it went from
relatively balanced chances to white
just having a crushing crushing an
advantage attack due to due to the
tactical combinations so why to move in
this position search for ideas and try
and find the the best continuation is
that a hand yeah
Queen g5 what side you know you want to
play g4 and then followed by Knight f5
it looks interesting I mean if you play
Queen g5 there's 94 Queen g5 94 know if
you're getting too much
keep searching for other ideas yeah
kingi - and then bring the Knight to e5
it's possible but you could walk into
Queen h3 check at some points help you
guys out a little bit here like visually
White is in a nice position like there
is there's all this pressure on the C
file and there is some potential
weaknesses on the King side that has
black I have to be very careful about
what Sam managed to do was exploit the
Queen side and the King side in one very
nice combination and it all starts with
kind of considering that this key first
move so b5 is a very critical first move
one of the most like forcing one of the
most natural position ideas but what
happens after b5 see take b5 play rook
c7 we could trade and then Queen e6
can win the pollen a7 so I'm gonna go
ahead and say he does play b5 but for a
completely different reason and I was
actually expecting this rook c7 line so
I took on me fine I was expecting rook
c7 rook takes c7 and then probably Queen
e6 and he does win back the pawn but I
thought I would be holding on and then
he caught me completely off guard it was
very shocking because after b5 and C
take me five
Brooke c7 is possible but there is
there's actually a completely winning
move for white in this position rook
takes c6
it doesn't quite work so you want to
trade twice on see it and play queen g5
not forcing enough when he does in this
position is incredibly forcing and the
whole point of b5 is he's opened up the
C file and now he has a very direct
forcing continuation so before I call on
anyone the question to ask is what is
the most forcing move more importantly
what is the most forcing line yes and I
know five is by far the most forcing
move if you plan out of five you have to
calculate if 9f5 Queen take a five trade
the Queen's and win the rough yeah so
now I got five watt upon take I find
between g5 check if I move King f8 you
win the rook on c8 and let's say 9 f 5
GTA v Queen g5 King h7 aha Kim G - very
nice move if not everyone followed all
dry arrows so the the main line is my
left 5 GTA v Queen g5 King h7 King G -
brilliant move to prepare a rook h1 with
the side file mate
and to my horror after not 5
there's no way to to not to get a losing
position as black it was really sad
they're very tricky and even like the
smallest differences between moves can
have a very big impact on the result
yeah
so I'm gonna I'm gonna show that right
now because that was speeding - if the
Queen were on e6 let's actually imagine
I want to play this position out 9f5
let's say G take a five Queen g5 and
then King G - so the whole so the whole
point would be if my cream irani six I
would have Queenie for check after Kim G
- my queen would be slightly more
centralized so to go back and actually
show this one moment because let me get
it on the board so Queenie six if like
goes for the same idea be five tick nine
to five pawn to got five Queen g5 King
h7
everything's held together for luck and
then King G - you should realize the
answer to your question f3
does not work because it ro takes you to
check and there's actually no way for a
white to effectively get the rook to h1
and probably black is the one who's
better here question oh no okay
so yeah after the game when he was
interviewed in the broadcast and then it
all made sense of why okay Queenie six
was so much better than Queen d7 but
during the game sometimes it's hard to
spot these differences without digging
very deep into the calculations so just
to wrap this up the game ended where I
did try and fight on I took on a five
with the Queen and then I was down in
exchange but then he just started
picking up pawns and then I resigned so
pretty sad finish then of course Jaclyn
went on to win the tournament and then
then shortly after he got his GM title
and did not retire yeah bro the book
about pawns yeah it's 829 I think we'll
end it here and then I have so many
puzzles prepared that probably next week
we'll just do a part two so this lecture
so hope you guys enjoyed that and now
it's time for Thai food thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]